hallo Christoph hallo Anna ja auch ich
habe heute mal eine kleine Frage und
zwar natürlich an Anna und ja es ist so
ich kenne Dich gar nicht also ich habe
dich wirklich noch nie gesehen ich bin
mal ehrlich hier an der Stelle und hab
halt mal die dieses Video gesehen von
Christoph von klickum wo darum ging dass
man die Fragen stellen konnte und da
kamst du echt aufgetrallert drüber und
ich weiß nicht vielleicht bist du ja
immer so dass auch meine Frage was bist
du so für ein Typ von Mensch also bist
du immer halt diese aufgetrahte Person
oder bist du ey ganz normal ruhig was
auch immer würd freuen wenn du es
beantwortest und ja dann falls ja danke
an klickst und dass ich mich die Frage
stellen lassen habt und ja dann tschüss
ähm also ob ich aufgetrellert bin und
wie ich bin also wie ich so persönlich
bin also ich muss sagen es gibt bei mir
immer so hoch und ab also manchmal bin
ich total wow alles cool und ich kann
aber auch ähm zu Tode zu Tode betrübt
sein also
ähm es hängt immer von der Stimmung ab
in der ich gerade so mich befinde also
wie
gesagt es gibt alles bei mir also wie
ich bin ich bin fröhlich ich bin lustig
ich bin aber auch total unlustig und
total unspontan kann ich auch sein ich
kann auch aggressiv
sein also ich ich glaube ich bin von
allem ein bisschen was und kommt immer
drauf an wie das Gegenüber mir
rüberkommt und welche Situation das
gerade ist ja ich glaube das
reicht